zero byte sulzer byte partiamo bene cari
a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fari genio ci siamo su ai mei
tai chapter 1 il vuoto
va bene sì sì sì sì sì non vuole non
c'ho voglia
leggo neanche le cose in italiano figura
ten inglese cosa devo fare a di spendere
bene non avevo voglia di giocare a
capendo perché mi ha travasato il
testicolo destro che mi sono messo a
giocare ad aimé ideye ho deciso di
giocarlo mentre devo andare a pisciare
di bestia quindi finiscono gameplay e
poi vado a pisciare di sicuro sta gas
catina non mi aiuta però vabbè ma ci
sono delle cinematiche in questo gioco
ma il gioco della vita ha chiesto il
source a kyoto stupido attenzione colpo
di scena che titani che ti devi solo
spostare mi sono venuti i brividi ve lo
giuro morti zero come funziona ma non mi
si muove più il personaggio è normale
aiuto non mi si muove io devo sbloccarmi
le gambe è molto più difficile di quanto
pensassi
ma porca vacca la si è pagato non
abbiamo neanche iniziato va bene è
bellissimo già che se vai nelle
impostazioni e metti in lingua
questo gioco è attualmente disponibile
solo in inglese
grazie all ottima questa pagina dei
settaggi allora perché non riesco a
muovermi maledizione di fitch ha la base
di questo gioco e muoversi ma neanche
quello riesco a fare
giocare ai giochi indie giorno d'oggi è
veramente difficile anche perché sarebbe
fantastico se io potessi muovermi cosa
mickey è successo a seclì col al tasto r
esploso per ricominciare [ __ ]
funzione posso esplodere ed è già un
passo avanti ma non passi avanti non ne
ho fatti di regia c'è qualcosa in più ve
lo giuro non si sta muovendo non
capitale che percepisce il joystick no
vabbè dai ribelli
c'era il joystick ha attaccato e quindi
non mi prendeva i comandi fantastico
ciao ho trovato difficoltà nel partire
quindi figuriamoci per il resto del
gioco va bene dai andiamo avanti solo
per capire di considerata per adesso
easy e fin qua se non vi comparisse
sempre il cursore del mouse che devo
spostare ogni volta che passo da un
livello all'altro sarebbe ancora meglio
però fa un rumore bellissimo quando
salva neanche quando muore è proprio
come il gioco di quando dici the floor
isla va da floris lava e non sono capace
di a giocare alle polemiche mi ricompare
sempre il cursore maledetto agenda ok
bene bene progressi io ho decide
altamente deciso che il cursore del
mouse lo lascerò lì per tutta la durata
del video perché mi sono strafalcioni
testicoli se avete qualcosa in contrario
calmiamoci tutti è così difficile da
aifa vj questi porca vacca un salto devo
fare un tutorial
mamma mia che finale allora adesso sei
live da far loro picchiarlo
no credo fare si si si staccano le
braccia ma agli devo prestare le braccia
che misteriosamente gli diventano di
sangue quando il resto con quale musica
di sottofondo me lo stai dicendo gioco
c'è la stessa musica di sottofondo me la
immagino quando rimorchio ok jolo per
adesso tutto bene anche perché ho
giocato supermicro e con quello ho
ripassato un sacco il vangelo che so
fare una domanda ma lascia la scelta
musicale che l'ha fatta a topo gigio
c'è prima mi hanno messo una canzone che
mi bastava anima adesso mi sembra di
sentire un pezzo dei toto ok ok perfetto
questo è un portale huayra pensavo fosse
mia zia grazie averne ho specificato
quanto mi turba quel maledetto fools ore
ma anche se lo sposto poi mi ricompare
maledizione che sono aiuto quando c'è un
degli occhi che mi fissa ce l'ho fatta
più
mammamia progaming raga qua perfetto
bene come fa una scatola di cartone a
distruggere una star o una lama
d'acciaio va bene non me lo voglio
neanche chiederla non lo so il sun
colonna sonora di sottofondo sembra
maestro beppe vessicchio che dirige
l'orchestra nel visto gioco ma
all'inizio non avevo visto gli occhi
quanto sono brutti tra l'altro ok ok sul
tesoro
cos'era se solo smacchia trovano mandato
niente che cos'era non ho capito ma va
bene c'è un altro sismica e bastano fa
non c'è niente dentro governo l'unico
tesoro in un videogioco non contiene
niente a sono monete forse è un busto di
monete potrebbe perché vedo la stessa
icona monet e là sopra quindi non si
dice più moneygrabber ma si dice scatola
grabber fermi tutti che io e mio marito
cursore che mi indica sempre la
direzione ti ringrazio di esserci
perfetto a sono dei dispenser di frecce
tipo quelli di minecraft ho capito che
se non ci fosse uno a sparare per ok
porca vacca quanto difficile a mi
piacevano team in bocca agli sponsor poi
ragazza parte un casino e nuvole vorrei
dire perfetto c'è poi sucate meno tutti
ecco scherzavo ragazzi è veramente più
incasinato di quanto possiate pensare
non sto scherzando
maledizione ma porca vacca perché non
salto ok mi sto ricordato di stata cosa
sono sti cosi ma gesù ma queste sono
delle larve
cos'è nei ter non capisco
madonna come mi sono salvato di niente
dovevo andare qua eh va beh questa sera
cologia peawees sembra quello quando ti
allontani da happy meals ma è più mi
stupì ne date sembra quello devi
scrivere le cose in happy with porca
vacca se viene facevo schifo anche a
quel gioco dove mi sposto io devo nesso
sti cosio all'inizio eva per quanto
difficile aiuto
raga nota è proprio lì dov'era navi che
in pali infatti questa parte ma basta
sta canzone mattina lo abbia tre nalini
ca porta avanti ma poi in check point
menti ce lo porta infame maledetta c'è
ma vi sembra possibile che tutto questo
senza prova a seguire il cursore seguo
il cursore indicami la strada traditore
schifoso
se vi spostava un attimino più a destra
era finito il livello
[Musica]
gesù parola se vuoi adesso
mamma mia so che ci avete sperato
maledetti perché siete persone orribili
in fondo e voi lo sapete di esserlo
maledizione è quanto problemi per quanto
può che proprio non so dire la parola
solo gamer
ecco infatti io mi immagino gli effetti
sonori che hanno fatto quando hanno
creato sto gioco
l'hanno fatto che la bocca ok ok ci sono
ma basta ma quanti livelli ci sono stai
attento ai missili guidati uno di ok
porca vacca sono esplosi bene
aiuto aiuto aiuto mamma c'è il casinò e
non ci arrivo come farlo devo schivarlo
proprio sono studiata bene stata
maledizione cioè se ne sono studiate
bene reparti visto gioco mi che ho fatto
a caso
ok dovevo passare molti maledizione
magari se non penso per due ore ma
[Musica]
madonna madonna cioè mi sta venendo la
rogna ve lo giuro ed andare a pisciare
da prima
basta
oggi tutti perché non c'è no no no no no
no quando la mettete un checkpoint
mettete non c'è quindi schifoso
maledetto fame l'aido pasta quante volte
la sto facendo ora ga ve lo giuro cioè
gironi stagnanti gesù
no
ma nello stile ma perché non si scrivano
quanto difficile albera smacchiato già
accesi grazie ci sono ci sono ci sono
ecco bene basta basta quanto 2 al suo
gioco basta voglio per avere una vita di
nuovo o che questo come lo schifo
scusatemi perfetto no no no no no no
salta bene o gesù quanto 34 problematico
arrivare fin qua figura praga non
vinciamo
c'è veramente visto trovando difficoltà
nel mantenere la calma
gesù
e va bene allora ma fate quello che
volete lo so onesto onesto tra zeus
morto l'altro il design di questi bossi
incredibile cioè proprio per de vita in
base a che cosa esattamente a in base a
quello che schifo e bellissimo che
questa musica qua ce la mettono solo nei
box nel resto del gioco ci sono colonne
sonore di degni di sanremo sono
diventato bravo pure ecco sapeva che io
parlo ma domanda che parlo ancora demo
pisciare devo veramente pisciare con un
drago e non c'è bisogno di giocare con
con sto tizio ma iniziamo
la salvezza divina basta basta va bene
mi son rotto le parraga si è stato bello
devo veramente andare a pisciare
dall'inizio del vino quindi vado adesso
spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa il
semplice un momento mi piace anche la
risorsa come sviziare sono tre con
sistemi ci vediamo
[Musica]